بينما تسابق فرق البحث والانقاذ الزمن
لانتشال الضحايا واخلاق المصابين العالقين
تحت الانقاض تسبقهم ارقام الجثث نحو
الارتفاع في سوريا تحديدا وفي مخيمات
ومناطق يرتجف سكانها بردا تفاقمت ماسيهم
اضعافا فلا ادوات انقاذ كافيه ولا مشاف
ولا مراكز صحيه تستقبل جرحى ما تسبب به
الزلزال ليس هذا فحسب فللمصادفه المؤسفه
طبعا ان عددا لا باس به من ضحايا الزلزال
في تركيا هم من اللاجئين السوريين
لتتضاعف تلك الكارثه وتزيد من بؤس
السوريين
الله اكبر
روح روح روح
[موسيقى]
يا شباب
اما وعن احدث ارقام الكارثه فقد خلفت
زلزال اكثر من 2000 قتيل في سوريا والاف
الجرحى وفقا طبعا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان وعلى الجانب الاخر من الحدود من
حدود هذا الزلزال فقد خلفت الكارثه اكثر
من اربعه الاف وخمسمائه قتيل وما لا يقل
عن سته وعشرين الفا وسبعمائه وهذا ايضا
غير المباني التي دمرت الزلزال وان ضرب
ضربته اصر على ان لا يغيب اذ سجل تركيا هز
ارتداديه جديده بقوه 5.6 درجات بمقياس
لتنضم الى اكثر من 300 هزه ارتداديه منذ
بدء الزلزال وفقا طبعا لاداره الكوارث
التركيه
[موسيقى]
عشر سنين احسنتي
يلا يلا
شوي بس
الضوء
[موسيقى]
العربيه جمعه يعني عدد من الدول بدات
بارسال المساعدات الى سوريا منذ امس كيف
هي وتيره هذه المساعدات هل وصلت الى اي
مناطق كيف يتعاطى النظام مع توسيع مع
توزيع هذه المساعدات
مساء الخير لك ايها الساده المشاهدين نعم
بدات طلائع المساعدات تصل الى مطار دمشق
الدولي في الصباح الباكر كان هناك طائرتان
عراقيه وصلتها الى المطار من المساعدات
الاغاثيه والطبيه وايضا البطانيه ايضا
لحقتها طائره من الجزائر وصلت الى مطار
حلب ثم طائره اخرى ايضا من الجزائر الى
مطار حلب الدولي منذ حوالي ثلاث ساعات
وهبط الطائره طائره يعني طائره اماراتيه
تعمل ايضا مساعدات انسانيه يعني هذه
المساعدات يستلمها قوات يعني تستلمها
يستلمها النظام السوري وعلى الاغلب يقوم
بتوجيهها الى المناطق المتضرره الواقعه
تحت صدرته لان هذه المساعدات لم يصل اي
اجزاء منها حتى هذه اللحظه الى المناطق
المنكوبه الخارجه عن سيطره النظام تحديدا
في مناطق المعارضه في ريفيل في في ريف
ادلب وريف حلب
الشمال اي شمال
سوريا المساعدات شحيحه جدا يعني حتى تلك
التي تقوم بتوزيعها المنظمات الدوليه عبر
الشركاء المحليين شمال غرب سوريا
والمنظمات الاخرى التابعه للامم المتحده
بشهادات سكان
ريف حلب الشمالي وادلب وعفرين جمعه بما
انك تتحدث عن يعني المنطقه الشماليه
وتحديدا المناطق المحاذيه هي اصلا تعيش ما
قبل هذا الزلزال بظروف ماساويه بالمخيمات
وايضا يعني بظروف انسانيه صعبه جدا اليوم
مع هذا الزلزال هناك ازمه بايصال هذه
المساعدات الى هناك هل من بوادر الى فتح
ممرات اضافيه وما الذي يحصل هناك
يعني فتح الممرات او فتح المنافذ الحدوديه
تعاني من معضلتين الماضله الاولى هي معضله
سياسيه غياب التنسيق السياسي او اي اتفاق
مبدئي او حتى مرحله بين المعارضه وبين
النظام لان المساعدات الدوليه الكبيره
عندما يعني تاتي الى سوريا عليها ان تسلك
اما مطر
دمشق وحلب الدوليين او المنافذ البحريه
خاصه الموانئ في الساحه السوريه وكل هذه
المرافز تقع تحت سيطرت النظام دون وجود
تفاهم اتفاق تنسيق اي اي نوع من يعني اي
عنوان من هذه العناوين مطلوب لهذه المرحله
او انها لن تستطيع هذه هذه المرحله الاولى
المرحله الثانيه يعني جميع يعني او اغلب
الدول العربيه
والدول الاوروبيه
على العلاقات وبالتالي ادخال المساعدات
سيحتاج الى نوع من التواصل او التنسيق مع
النظام
وبالتالي هذا ايضا يفسر انه المساعدات
الدوليه التي وعدت بها حوالي 47 دوله لم
تتدفق على سوريا لا بمناطق النظام ولا حتى
الى مناطق المعارضه ما يفسر غيابها عن
مناطق المعارضه اذا كانت تريد ان تسلك
الطريق من تركيا
معبر باب الهوى مفتوح غير مغلق وهو المعبر
الشرعي الذي تعترف به يعني
الاعضاء الخمس اليه التصويت
بنعم والادخال المساعدات متاحه حتى اربع
اشهر اخرى لكن الظروف الكارثه التي
تعانيها تركيا وانقطاع طرق يعني الوضع
الوضع الانساني العام
يجعل من الصعب خاصه في الولايات المحاذيه
لهذا المعبر يجعل من الصعب وصول المساعدات
الامويه او الدوليه الى هذا
الخبر الذي يبدو انه حتى الان غير مفعل
ولم يشهد يقول اي مساعدات ملحوظه عبره
باتجاه المناطق المنكوبه في شمال شرق شمال
غرب البلاد جمعه يعني بالساعات الماضيه
كان هناك نقص كبير بالمعدات الطبيه
بالمستشفيات والتي هي اصلا تعاني منها
سوريا ما قبل هذا الدمار وايضا نقص
بالمعدات اللازمه لانتشال الضحايا
والناجين من تحت هذه الانقاذ هل يعني تم
شحن اي من هذه المعدات مساعده الدوله
السوريه فيها هناك
يعني الى مناطق
اللاذقيه
يعني حلب الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي الى حماه الى طرطوس نعم وصلت بعض
المساعدات هناك حتى فرق انقاذ متخصصه جاءت
من الجزائر ومن لبنان
يعني فرق من الجيش الروسي يعني اعداد من
الجيش الروسي يساعدونا يعني الاجهزه
المعنيه يعني في منطقه النظام في انتشال
في رفع الركام وتشال الجرحى والجثث
والباقين على قيد الحياه من هذه المنطقه
لكن في مناطق المعارضه المهمه فقط بالدفاع
الذاتي وبعض المتطوعين الشباب والاهالي
الذين يقومون بازاله الانقاض وتجريفها عبر
يعني ادوات بدائيه وبسيطه بينها مثلا اليد
اعتياديه لرفع الانقاذ والجرافات لايذا
لازالتها او ابعادها عن المناطق التي يعني
اغلى خاصه الطرق الرئيسيه جمعه شكرا لك
جمعه عكاش مراسل العربيه من القامشلي على
ساعود اليك في حال يعني ورود اي جديد
وايضا لمتابعه التطورات ونقل
الصور شكرا لك الجمعه
وجه العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجهها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا
وسوريا وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه
وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار الزلزال والتي ستنطلق
اعتبارا من يوم غد كما وجه الملك سلمان
والامير محمد بتنظيم حمله شعبيه عبر منصه
ساهم لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال
مزيد من التفاصيل معنا من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن هذه
المبادره وهذه المساعدات التي اطلقتها
المملكه قبل قليل يعني بموازاه الكارثه
الانساني الانسانيه التي حلت بتركيا
وسوريا تفاصيلها معك
نعم بالفعل منذ وقوع الكارثه كان هنالك
تواصل سعودي على اعلى المستويات منذ هذا
منذ وقوعها على مستوى تركيا وحتى على
مستوى
الجوانب الاغاثيه والانسانيه لتقديم
المزيد من الدعم والاستعداد لتقديم هذا
الدعم منذ يوم الامس عند الاتصال الذي جرى
بين ولي العهد السعودي والرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في صباح هذا اليوم وفي ساعات
متاخره من مساء يوم الامس حيث تمت التعزيه
من قبل ولي العهد السعودي والعهد السعودي
لتركيا وتقديم الاستعداد لتقديم كافه
المعونات لتركيا لتجاوز هذه الكارثه
الطبيعيه اليوم فعلا كان هنالك استعدادات
كبيره جدا بدلا من الحظها منذ
صباح هذا اليوم في الاستعداد لتسيير جسر
جوي وما ان حل المساحه تتم الاعلان عن هذا
الجسر الجوي والتوجيه من القياده السعوديه
من ولي العهد السعودي والعهد السعودي لهذه
هذا الجسر الجوي الذي سيبدا منذ يوم غد
وايضا بجانبه ايضا سيكون هنالك حمله شعبيه
سعوديه
لاغاثه الشعبين التركي
والسوري توازيا في هذه الازمه الطبيعيه
والكارثه التي حلت بهذين الشعبين وتحديدا
في المناطق المتضرره كان هنالك حديث قبل
قليل من قبل مسؤولين مركز الملك سلمان
قالوا بانهم هذه المساعدات ستكون صحيه
بشكل
مباشر ايضا اغاثيه وايضا فرق انقاذ
بالاضافه الى العديد من الاجهزه الطبيه
والطائرات التي ستحمل كافه
مساعدات اللازمه ويبدو انك كان هنالك
تنسيق بين القياده السعوديه
والتركيه على هذا الصعيد بخصوص الاحتياج
هما وسرعه وصول هذه المساعدات فبالتالي
سيبدا غدا هذا الجسر الجوي محاولا بكل هذه
المساعدات الطبيه
والايوائيه ايضا بالاضافه الى وجود خبراء
من مركز الملك سلمان
للتواجد في المناطق المتضرره ليس فقط على
مستوى تركيا ولكن حتى على مستوى سوريا حيث
قبل قليل كان هنالك حديث من قبل المتحدث
الرسمي لمركز الملك سلمان بانه سيكون
هنالك فرقيه ستدخل الى الداخل السوري ايضا
سيكون هنالك
مساعدات وتقديمها بشكل مباشر للشعب السوري
والمناطق المتضرره بشكل مباشر في سوريا
اذا حمله كبيره
لكافه وعموم الشعب السعودي عند الساعه
الواحده ظهرا بتوقيت الرياض ستنطلق وسيكون
هنالك تبرعات كبيره جدا من قبل
السعوديين والمواطنين والمقيمين على حد
سواء سيكون عبر منصه الكترونيه تجمع هذه
التبرعات لتصب مباشره في
هذه المساعدات التي يتم ارسالها ايضا هناك
مساعدات حكوميه مباشره ستنطلق يوم الغد
وايضا مساعدات شعبيه مباشره ستكون بعد جمع
هذه الاموال التي سيتبرع بها الشعب
السعودي وكذلك المقيمين والمواطنين عبر
هذه المنصه الالكترونيه المساعدات ليست
فقط على مستوى
عاجل والايام او الساعات القليله القادمه
بل ستمتد اكثر الى مرحله ما بعد هذه
الكارثه تحدث مسؤولون مركز الملك سلمان
الى انهم سيكونون متواجدين حتى بعد
بعد الايام للمساعده في عمليه اعاده
الاعمار واعاده بناء البيوت الى وضعها
السابق واعاده كل
المساهمه في اعاده كل مكان علي والحياه
الطبيعيه ان تعود الى مجرياتها عبر خبراء
ومنسقي وايضا مسؤولي مركز الملك سلمان
الذي سيتواجدون على اعلى مستوى في المناطق
التركيه والسوريه على حد سواء بدن من يوم
غاد نحن نتحدث عن مبادره انسانيه انقاذيه
حكوميه لنجده الشعب السوري بعد هذه
الكارثه التي حلت به وهو طبعا الشعب
المنكوب منذ بدء هذه الحرب شكرا لك مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي على هذه
الرساله من الرياض
في ادلب تحديدا في مدينه حارم وبنظرات
مليئه بالامل طفله تصمد بجانب شقيقها
الاصغر تحت الانقاض بعد اكثر من 20 ساعه
احسن منك
اذا جبت شو
طالعين
جنازه تلو الاخرى هذا هو الحال في مدينه
حلب بعد الزلزال فلنتابع
يعني كل خمس دقايق بيجينا اربع خمس اشخاص
الله يرحمهم ويعني ما عاد لحقنه ومستمرين
بالشغل نحن يعني هلا اليوم الصبح لهلا صار
تجوز العدد فوق الخمسين
امبارح بحدود 80 الله يرحمهم فتاخر علينا
الدفن لانه صار جسد طلعت مي مع بعضها في
وقت في مسافه يعني الساعه 11:30 بالليل
وجسد الصبح
حاولنا انه نجمع الجثث ندفنهم فردا مثل ما
شايفين هلا هون في معنا اذاعه جثه وبعدنا
جثه مفقوده لسه ما طلعت
الله يصبرنا فيكم يا ربي دخيلك زبر الربيع
قل لا اله الا الله
منير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري استاذ منير يعني سابدا بالسؤال عن
الاطفال بما اننا كنا نشاهد معانات هؤلاء
بعد هذا الزلزال خصوصا وان اطفال سوريا
يعني بحسب التقارير الدوليه يعانون اسوا
المعاناه حول العالم كيف هي والوضع من
هناك كيف يمكن نقل الماسات من هناك
في الحقيقه وضع الاطفال زاد سوءا بوجود
هذا الزلزال في
بسوريا مثل هذه الحاله لم تمر من قبل على
الشعب السوري الاطفال صراحه كانوا يعانون
منذ عشر سنوات لنقص في في المواد في نقص
في التعليم لنقص في الحالات التي يجب ان
ترافق اعمارهم من العاب ومن منتزهات ومن
اماكن يعني يقضون بها اوقاتهم للاسف زاد
هذه المعاناه البارحه
وجود هذا الزلزال فهم كانوا من العالقين
تحت الانقاذ كانوا ممن ينتظرون فرق
الاغاثه وفرق الدفاع المدني والخوز
البيضاء حتى يصل اليهم وينتشلهم من تحت
الانقراض الصراحه فرق الفوز البيضاء تصارع
الزمن تصارع الوقت حتى تستطيع ان تسحب
العالقين من تحت الانقراض حتى تستطيع ان
تنتشل
العالقين قبل ان بالامكانات الموجوده
اليوم بالداخل السوري هل يمكن القول بانكم
تستطيعون يعني انت انت ان تعملون اللازم
هناك بخصوصا اننا نتحدث عن كارثه كبيره
وعن امكانات ضئيله
في الحقيقه نحن منذ الساعات الاولى من
حصول هذه الكارثه وجهت الخبز البيضاء نداء
استغاثه الى كل دول العالم من اجل تقديم
العون ومد يد العون والمساعده وايصال
الفرق الاغاثيه وايصال المعدات التي
تستخدم برفع الانقراض وايصال المعدات التي
تستخدم ايضا يعني برفع الصبات البيتونيه
المتراكمه فوق بعضها هذا النداء عبر
قناتكم وعبر كافه الاقنيه التلفزيونيه وجه
هذا النداء حتى الان لم يصل اي شيء من هذه
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا حتى الان
ننتظر وصولها ونحن نصارع الزمن يعني حقيقه
اول 72 ساعه من هذه اكله ستكون هي ساعات
مفصليه بحيث في هذا الوقت نستطيع ان ننتشر
والاحياء نعم استاذ منير يعني بشمال غرب
سوريا بالايام الماضيه قبل هذا كانت هذه
المنطقه تعاني من تبعات حاله الطقس هناك
حاله يعني انسانيه كانت اضاءه عليها
الكثير من وسائل الاعلام ان كان العربيه
والغربيه نتحدث عن حاله انسانيه صعبه جدا
مع هذا الزلزال كيف تفاقم الوضع وهل
المساعدات كافيه اذا وصلت طبعا الى هذه
المناطق
في الحقيقه حاله الطقس يعني يمكن ان نتكلم
بها على شقين الشق الاول هم الموجودين تحت
الانقاض ينتظرون الفرق الاغاثه لانتشالهم
من تحت الانقاذ وهم يعانون من كسور وجروح
وردود وهذا النزيف الحاصل في اجسادهم
حقيقه يعطي الاجسام بروده وبروده الطقس
تزيد من بروده هذه الاجساد وتزيد من فرصه
فقدان هذه الاجساد الانقاض الحاله الاخرى
هي حاله من تضررت منازلهم ومن تهدمت
منازلهم وهم الان موجودون في العراء فرق
التطوعيه مع الخوذه البيضاء في الداخل
قاموا بانشاء بعض المخيمات لاواء هؤلاء
السكان وابعادهم عن المنازل المتصدعه التي
ستكون هي ايضا عرضه للسقوط في الهزات
الاعتداديه التي تحصل حصل حصل عشرات من
الهزاز الابتدائيه ولكن حقيقه الوضع صعب
جدا
اذا اردت ان تتوجه اليوم للمنظمات الدوليه
دول العالم ما الذي تطلبونه بهذه المناطق
بالذات خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن نقص كبير على
كل المستويات
نطلب وبشكل عاجل وسريع ايصال اليات لرفع
الكتل الاسمنتيه الكبيره لايصال معدات
لفرق البحث والانقاذ حتى تساهم برفع
الانقاض من مبعدات هيدروليكيه ومن مخدات
هوائيه حتى تستخدم فرق الفوز البيضاء طبعا
يملك الخواز البيضاء جزء من هذه المعدات
ولكنها غير كافيه ايضا نطالب بايصال فرق
تساند فرق انصرا تساعد فرق القوات البيضاء
في شمال غرب سوريا من اجل تقديم المساعده
والاسراع بايصال هذه المساعدات حتى نستطيع
ان ننتشر العالقين وهم احياء قبل ان
ننتشلهم للاسف بعد اذا تاخرنا عليهم وهم
في عداد الاموال شكرا لك استاذ منير
المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري
حدثنا من شمال ادلب
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اضنه زيدان زنكلو
مراسل العربيه زيدان يعني بعد المساعدات
الدوليه على كافه الصعد التي بدات تصل الى
تركيا منذ الامس كيف هي الصوره اليوم كيف
يمكن وصف الواقع بعد 24 ساعه او اكثر من
هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
نعم بدايه انا اعتذر اني ساتحدث بصوت
منخفض نوعا ما بناء على طلب من فرق
الانقاذ التي تحاول سماع اصوات الناجين
تحت هذا او تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى المدمر
طلبوا من الجميع الصمت واغلاق الهواتف
المحموله حتى يتمكنوا من التواصل مع اشخاص
قبل قليل سمعنا تكبيرات وصلتهم اصوات من
الداخل تشير الى وجود اشخاص ناجين
وبالتالي الان يحاولون التاكد من انهم
ايضا ما زالوا يعملون او فرق الانقاذ ما
زالت تعمل بالاتجاه الصحيح وتحاول
الاقتراب منهم اكثر فاكثر الصمت يسود هذا
المكان تقريبا مئات من عمال الانقاذ
موجودون هنا
وعشرات الاليات كل الجميع في صمت تام في
محاوله
للبقاء مع رجال الانقاذ لسماع الاصوات على
ما يبدو ان هناك اشخاص ناجين يحاولون
الوصول اليهم في المبنى الموجود في شارع
تورته اوزال الذي انهار وهو مبنى مكون من
14 طابقا انهار نتيجه الزلزال المدمر الذي
شهدته البلاد فجر يوم امس كما
نتابع الان اعمال الانقاذ ستستمر على ما
يبدو انهم وصلوا او سمعوا ايضا صوتا
وهم بالتالي سيحاولون الوصول
والناجين الذين يتواجدون في هذا المبنى
بالتالي ستتواصل او بدات من جديد اعمال
الحفر لازاله الكتل الخرسانيه
والدمار الكبير الموجود في هذا المبنى في
محاوله للوصول الى ناجين جدد كما اخبرنا
احد رجال انقاذ قبل قليل انه من هذا
المبنى تم انتشال او تم اخراج خمسه اشخاص
كانوا على قيد الحياه وما زالوا يسمعون
اصوات ذلك يحاولون مجددا
التكثيف العمل الاليات اليات كبيره وصلت
الى المكان للمساهمه في عمليات الانقاذ
بالعموم يعني هذا فيما يخص هذا الموقع
فيما يخص فيما يخص عمليات
في كل الولايات وبحسب ما شاهدناه يعني
بالحديث عن المساعدات طبعا لا شك ان اكثر
من 3000 شخص من طواقم اجنبيه يشاركون هذا
اليوم في عده ولايات متضرره باعمال
الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين هناك فريق اتى
مثلا من المانيا ومن روسيا وايضا من عده
دول يشاركون في اعمال التنقيب ايضا هناك
مساعدات وصلت من عده دول شاهدتها انا عند
وصولي الى مطار اضنه من مثلا من الجزائر
ومصر والاردن والرومانيا نعم
يعني صوت عمليات الانقاذ مع الصوره ثم ثم
نعود يعني لنستمع للتفاصيل معك
[موسيقى]
زيدان
زيدان كنا نتحدث عن يعني اطقم الطوارئ
التي وصلت هل يعني قبل ان نكمل هذا الحديث
بما اننا يعني نرى صوره عمليات الانقاذ
التي ما زالت مستمره وستستمر بسعه المقبله
هل هناك اي تقديرات للاعداد المفقوده التي
مازال تحت ركام هذه المباني
نعم لا توجد حتى من خلال ما شاهدناه هنا
لا يعلمون بالضبط كم شخص موجود في الاسفل
لكن قالوا انهم سمعوا اصوات من اكثر من
شخص وبالتالي هم يقدرون ان هناك عده اشخاص
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
اتحدث عن ارقام اجماليه
بالعموم بالعموم طبعا طبعا انا انطلقت هذا
المبنى لاتحدث في العموم وايضا في العموم
لا توجد تقديرات حقيقيه او حتى تقريبيه
لاعداد الاشخاص الذين موجودين هم تحت
الانقاض حتى الان الامور هناك نوعا ما
اضطراب بسبب هول ما حدث يعني اذا تحدثنا
عن الولايات العشره التي تاثرت بالزلزال
واجراء فيها دمار نتحدث عن ولايات تضم
اكثر من حوالي او حوالي 13 مليون شخص
يقيمون في هذه الولايات وبالتالي امكانيه
حصر الاضرار او معرفه اعداد الاشخاص الذين
كانوا موجودين او ما زالوا موجودين
الانقاض حتى الان تبدو الامور صعبه نوعا
ما او ربما صعبه خلال المدى القريب لكن
ربما مع استمرار العمليات ومع اكتمال
مراكز ربما والحديث مع كل الاهالي في
مراكز واربما يكون هناك ارقام تقديريه
للاشخاص الذين ما زالوا عالقين تحت
الانقاض لكن حتى الان لا يمكن او حتى
الحكومه التركيه لم تعطي ارقام تقديريه عن
اعداد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت الانقاذ
زيدان بالعوده للحديث عن العمليات
الاغاثيه او عن المساعدات التي تصل الى
تركيا هل هي كافيه هل ما زالت تطلب
الحكومه التركيه مزيد من المساعدات
نعم لا شك ان الحكومه التركيه طبعا الاثر
الكارثه كبير وكما تقول انها هي اكبر
كارثه تشهدها ليس فقط تركيا بل المنطقه
وهي من اكبر الكوارث على مستوى العالم
نظرا لحجم الضرر الذي وقع في عشر ولايات
نتحدث كما ذكرت عيد المعلومه السابقه هذه
الولايات يقطنها حوالي 13 مليون شخص
وبالتالي امكانيه يعني ان حجم الضرر الذي
جرى في هذه الولايات كبير جدا مبدئيا هناك
حاجه كبيره بدايه لانتشال او لازاله
الانقاض والوصول الى اكبر عدد من الناجين
تحت الانقاض ومن ثم انتشال ايضا الضحايا
واسعاف المصابين هذه هذه هي الاولويه
الاولى ايضا الاولويه الثانيه والتي لا
تقل اهميه وهي موضوع ايجاد ماوى لكل
الاشخاص الذين خرجوا من منازلهم وهم الان
في دور ايواء مؤقته او في الشوارع او حتى
في اماكن مفتوحه او في الحدائق والمنتزهات
ايضا نقطه مهمه لذلك اليوم الحكومه
التركيه يعني اعتبارا من هذا اليوم كان
الحديث عن استخدام الفنادق في المناطق
السياحيه الرئيسيه وذكر الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ولايه انطاليا على وجه
التحديد لان هذه الولايه تمتلك اعداد كبير
من اعداد كبيره من الفنادق وبالتالي يمكن
الاستفاده من هذه الفنادق لاواء اعداد
ربما قد تصل الى 50 الف في كل الفنادق
الموجوده في منطقه بحر ايجا او حتى في
انطاليا او حتى يمكن نقل اعداد الى ولايات
او اعداد من
الذين يريدون ماوى الى ولايات اخرى طبعا
هذه هي المرحله الاولى المرحله الثانيه هي
التاكد من المباني التي لم تنهار المباني
التي فيها تصدعات وتشققات ومن ثم تقييم
حجم الاضرار وهل يجب هدم هذا هذه الابنيه
ام ترميم هذه الابنيه بشكل
بحيث ان تكون هذه الابنيه لائقه وجاهزه
للسكن مجددا ومن ثم المرحله وهي اعاده
اعمار المباني او المناطق المدمره ومن ثم
جلب او نقل السكان اليها
الضعيه ونقطه قريبه من مكان الانقاذ قدر
ما تستطيع وان نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
لعمليه الانقاذ لو سمحت
المشكله نحن نقف كما اذا شاهدتم هذا
الشريط الذي وضعته الشرطه نحن نقف عند اخر
نقطه يسمح لنا كصحفيين واشخاص لا ننتمي او
لسنا من كوادر
طبعا بالعدسه سنحاول الاقتراب اكثر
بالعدسه
طبعا سنحاول الدخول اكثر في العمق لمشاهده
المحاولات المستمره لكن كما ذكرت نحن
تقريبا بعيدون فقط 20 متر عن هذا المبنى
المدمر لكن هذه اخر نقطه يسمح للصحفيين
وغير الصحفيين
هم غير
طواقم
زيدان ابقى معي سانتقل الى وزيري الصحه
والدفاع التركي في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
ومجموع الجرحى 590 جريح يتلقون في مستشفى
مرسين واما في
الجرحى تم ارسالهم وسيتم الى مستشفى
اضنه الان في مستشفى اضنه
هناك 220 جريحا في العينين المركزه
ومجموعه عدد الجرحى 600 جريح يواصلون تلقي
العلاج في مستشفى اضنه وكذلك في الريحانيه
الموجوده في هذه المدن تقدم الخدمات
للجرحى
وضحايا زلزال واما الجرح الذي جراحاتهم
خطيره فقد فننقلهم بالطائرات والمروحيات
الى انقره اسطنبول وقد تم نقله 300 جريح
تقريبا بهذا الشكل مواطنون الاعزاء
[موسيقى]
حكومه التركيه تسعى بكل قوتها لتضميد هذه
الجراحات
ونشكر مواطنين الذين يسعون بكل جهدهم
لتضمير جراحات اخوانهم يجب ان لا ننسى ان
كل الكوارث التي واجهناها معا ونجحنا في
مواجهتها نجحتنا في ذلك بالتعاون والتضامن
والتكاتف واليوم كذلك الامر ننتظر من
شعبنا الدعاء شكرا جزيلا
مواطنون الاعزاء
احييكم بخالص المحبه والتقدير كما ذكر
السيد الوزير نحن نواجهه كارثه عظيمه لكن
نحن نواجه هذا نستطيع ان نواجه هذا
بالتعاون والتضامن والتكاثف في دوله وشعبا
وبالسعي والعمل والمكافحه معا وسنضمن
الجراحاتنا معا في هذا اطاق هناك مساعي
مكثفه
وفي هذا الاطار اشكر كل عاملين
اود ان اذكرهم بالشكر والتقدير
هذا الزلزالي مباشره قمنا بمساعينا عرضنا
اول التطورات للسيد رئيس الجمهوريه وثم
قمنا باعمالنا نحن كوزاره الدفاع افتتحنا
مراكز اداره الازمات
بعد الفحوص الاولى والدراسات الاولى كانت
اولوياتنا هي اجساد فرق البحث والانقاذ
ونقل فرق البحث والانقاذ والمساعدات
الانسانيه وفور ذلك
اصدرنا التعليمات للقيام بذلك فورا دون
انتظار وانشانا مساعدات جويه وفي هذا
الاطار نواصل اعمالنا
لدينا طائرات كبيره فيها 400 ام
ومن طائرات
الجويه التي هي اقل ساحه تاثر بالظروف
المناخيه السيئه ننقل عبر الطائرات
المساعدات
يقومون
بالمساعده ونقل المساعدات
وقمنا بناكل المساعدات الى مطار انجل
يتواصلوا هذا النقل وفي هذا الاطار
المجموعه الجويه 75 مركبه طائره بما في
ذلك المروحيه والطائرات
مستشفى ميداني تم تاسيس
طبعا
اثناء عوده الطائرات الى مدن غرب تركيا
نقوم بنقل الجرحى الى المستشفيات في غرب
تركيا وايضا من يلعبون في الانتقال الى
المحافظات الغرب نطيح لهم استخدام هذه
الطائرات للتنقل
طبعا هنا اكثر المركبات الجويه فعاليه هنا
هي المروحيات تعمل بشكل فعال
عاملنا على انشاء مخيم لوجستي في
وهناك تقول مروحيات باعمالها
ويكون مجموع
المروحيات هنا سيتزايد ليصل الى 45 مجروحه
تقريبا في هذا الخيمه الجوي فقط طبعا
المساعدات التي كنا نقوم بها عبر انجي
نقوم بها مباشره وهذا طبعا سهل اعمالنا
كثيرا الظروف المناخيه تتابعها عن كثب
خساره
في مطار هطاي
الذي تاثر بشكل سيء متاح دي نزول الطائرات
لكن تاثر سلبا بالظروف المناخيه
الجنود الجنود التركي كما كان ناجحا في
مكافحه الارهاب وكذلك اليوم يقف جنبه الى
جنب مع هذا الشعب
وما يقارب 7500 جندي يعمل فعليا الان في
الميادين اضافه الى ذلك ابتداء من الغد
ينضاف اليهم 1500 جندي اخر اليهم وطبعا
القوات الكومندس تسعه طوابير من طوابير
تشاركهم وايضا اربع طواب متواجده في
الجمهوريه شمال في جمهوريه قبرص تشارك في
اعمالي المساعدات هذه وايضا متابعه تطورات
في هطي كذلك خصوصا بشان ملف الامن ومساعده
فرق البحث والانقاذ الجنود يواصلون
اعمالهم
بواقع 1300 جدي
ولتسهيل اعمالهم هناك فرق الانقاذ من
الكوارث الطبيعيه
فرق مؤهله
تمتلك الخبره واسعه وايضا الفرق القادمه
من طبرس
وطابوق الاستقلال ايضا تم جلبه الى هنا
للمشاركه في اعمال المساعدات والى جانب
ذلك لتسهيل الاعمال والظروف المعيشيه هنا
الاسهامات في هذا الاطار لنا اسهامات ايضا
هنالك المطابخ المتنقله 25 مطبخ متنقل
يقدم خدمته في مناطق الكوارث وايضا
14 عربه متنقيه توفيقي احتياجات الاستحمام
وايضا قمنا
باحضار المعدات اللازمه
للحفريات لاعمال الحفريات للانقاذ وبخصوص
الخبز ايضا هناك الاعمال الخدمات المساعده
المساعده والخدمات الرئيسيه كالافران
المتنقله واعراب توزيع الخبز المتنقله
بدانا فيها وسنبدا في الاستمرار الخبز
الجاهز
اذا مشاهدينا اكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر
الصحفي لكل من وزير الصحه ووزير الدفاع
التركي ساعود الى اضنه وزيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان يعني تحدث الوزيران الان عن
حاله تاهب قصوى على كافه الصعد وعن جسر
جوي داخلي لتامين كل الاحتياجات الطبيه
الانسانيه وغيرها ما الذي يعني يحصل هناك
وهل وعن هذه الخطه التي تقوم بها الحكومه
نعم
الحكومه التركيه الان وتحديدا وزاره
الدفاع هي التي انشات هذا الجسر الجوي
تحاول نقل جميع المستلزمات اللازمه لعمليه
الانقاذ عمليه الانقاذ وايضا هي عمليه
الايواء يعني الجسر الجوي يشمل شقين الاول
ايصال اكبر كم من المساعدات والاليات
والسيارات الاسعاف واطقم الانقاذ والتواقم
الطبيه الى الاماكن المنكوبه وايضا يحاول
ايصال المواد التي تساعد الاشخاص الذين ما
زالوا في العراء او حتى في داخل مراكز
الايواء على الصمود نتحدث عن مستلزمات
الشتويه البطانيات والاغطيه وايضا الاغذيه
وايضا حتى الاسعافات الاوليه او المواد
الطبيه والادويه التي هم بحاجه اليها مثلا
كبار السن او النساء الحوامل او حتى
لديهم امراض مزمنه يتم توفير هذه
المواد من خلال الجسر الجوي الذي اعلنت
عنه الحكومه التركيه فيما يتعلق كما ذكرنا
قبل قليل الشق الاخر من الجسر الجوي وهو
موضوع ايصال
حاله طوارئ طبيه غاثيه غذائيه على كافه
الصعد ساعود اكمل معك تفاصيل كل هذه
العمليه الانقاذيه التي تقوم بها الحكومه
التركيه ولكن اسمح لي ان نعود بالكاميرا
الى مكان الذي يتم فيه في هذه الاثناء
عمليه الاغاثه لو سمحت
نعم نعم سنحاول الدخول اكثر حركه السير في
الشارع المجاور بعدما تاكد رجال الانقاذ
من وجود بانهم يحفرون او الاعمال الحفر
تسير باتجاه الصحيح للوصول الى الناجين
بعد قبل دقائق كما سمعنا او دمتم معنا
طلبوا من الجميع الصمت لسماع اللاجئين
والحديث معهم وكما كنت اسمع من هنا كانوا
يطلبون منهم الصبر والانتظار قليلا بانه
وانهم باتوا قريبين نوعا ما من الوصول
اليهم لذلك اعمال الحفر تستمر وايضا
الحركه فيها هذا الشارع المجاور سمح بها
نوعا ما حتى نتحدث الحركه في الشوارع
المجاوره قليله لكن
الشرطه قطعت كل
الطبيعي لو سمحت
نعم نعم ساحاول تقريب المايك الى
عمليات الحفر
[موسيقى]
زيدان زيدان شكرا لك سنعود اليك طبعا بعد
قليل ولكن ابقي لنا صوره مفتوحه لو سمحت
لنتمكن من رصد عمليه اغاثه الناجين وطبعا
انتشال الضحايا على امل ان يكون الجميع
ناجين تحت ركام هذا المبنى
[موسيقى]
كارثه طبيعيه تزيد معاناتك وارث الحرب
السوريه التي امتدت 12 عاما والامل الوحيد
للحظات ما بعد الزلزال المرعب الذي ضرب
المنطقه يتجسد في المساعدات الانسانيه
التي تقدمها الدول الا انه في الحاله
السوريه تكون الكوارث الطبيعيه تابعه
للتقسيمات الجغرافيه ايضا ليضرب الزلزال
الجزء المعقد من خريطه سوريا منقسما بين
مناطق النظام السوري في الجزء الاكبر من
حلب ومناطق المعارضه المنقسمه بين نفسها
حتى بين ادلب في جنوبها تحت سيطره ما تسمى
بجبهه تحرير الشام وشمالها بالاضافه لريف
حلب الشمالي والذي تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه التابعه لتركيا
من عده جهات للتوصل الى معاهده تمحي
التعقيدات الجغرافيه وتوحد الحاله
الانسانيه التي يعيشها الشمال السوري
والسماح بدخول المساعدات
يجب على جميع الجهات الدوليه بما في ذلك
روسيا ان تستخدم نفوذها على النظام السوري
لضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه للضحايا
وتجنب العوائق الاضافيه
واسم انتشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يعزو صعوبه وصول المساعدات الى العقوبات
الدوليه المفروضه على سوريا الا ان
الخارجيه الامريكيه نفت ان يكون قانون
قيصر عائقا في هذه الحاله
ليس هناك اي شيء على الاطلاق في قانون
قيصر والعقوبات الامريكيه يمنع المساعده
الانسانيه عن الشعب السوري
في ظل غياب سلطه موحده تحكم جميع المناطق
السوريه في الشمال تزيد شده اثر الزلازل
المدمره والتشتت في تقديم المساعدات
والاغاثه وقدرات استيعاب المشافي في
المناطق المقيده ضمن حدود معينه عمر
العربيه
في غضون ذلك قالت كبيره مسؤولي مكتب
الطوارئ بمنظمه الصحه العالميه ان عدد
المتضررين بالزلزال المدمر قد يصل الى 23
مليونا مضيفه ان من بين المتضررين نحو
خمسه ملايين في حاله ضعف
من المحتمل ان يتعرض 23 مليون شخص بينهم
نحو مليونين من الفئات السكانيه الضعيفه
الى جانب اكثر من 300 وخمسين الفا من كبار
السن ونحو مليون و400 الف طفل لقد تضررت
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه
الصحيه في جميع انحاء المناطق المتضرره
ولا سيما في تركيا وشمال غربي سوريا الى
جانب الدمار الهائل تعطلت الطرق في العديد
من المناطق وعبر الحدود داخل شمال غرب
سوريا تدرك منظمه الصحه العالميه قدره
تركيا القويه على الاستجابه وتعتبر ان
الاحتياجات الرئيسيه التي لم تتم تلبيتها
قد تكون في سوريا على المدى القريب
والمتوسط
اذا كانت هذه مقاطعه لكان تم تفتيش هذا
المبنى نحن تحت الثلج بلا منزل بدون اي
شيء دعونا نستعد للجنازات هل انتحر ماذا
علي ان افعل اين يمكنني ان اذهب
حاول الساعه الثانيه مساء امس انهار هذا
المبنى ربما هناك مئات المباني الاخرى مثل
هذا هناك الالاف تحت الالقاب حاليا
السلطات التركيه لن يسمح لنا بانقاذهم
بوسائلنا لكنهم لا يرسلون اي شخص للمساعده
مشاهدينا ينضم جواد الروشت مراسل العربيه
ومن واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
ومن باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل العربيه سابدا
معك ناديه بما اننا نتحدث اليوم عن نفي
امريكا ان يكون قانون قيصر يعيق وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا ما هي الاليه لوصول
المساعدات الى هناك وماذا عن المساعدات
الامريكيه
الاليه ليال هي العمل مع المنظمات غير
الحكوميه المنظمات الامميه والمنظمات
الانسانيه التي تعمل في شمال سوريا وشمال
غرب سوريا وهذا هو واقع الحال منذ فتره
طويله في الواقع الاداره الامريكيه دوما
كانت تقول بان كل العقوبات المفروضه على
سوريا على النظام السوري بالتحديد ليس فقط
عقوبات قيصر لكن كل العقوبات دوما تستثني
المساعدات الانسانيه من دواء ومن اغذيه
بغض النظر اذا كان هناك كارثه طبيعيه ام
لا طبعا بحلول
الزلزال والدمار الذي احدثه في سوريا كانت
هناك حاجه امريكيه بالفعل لايصال كل هذه
المساعدات طبعا المساعدات تتم عبر الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه وهي ذراع وزاره
الخارجيه التي ارسلت اليوم 161 عامل اغاثه
ضمن طواقم تحركت من الولايات المتحده الى
تركيا وتحاول طبعا هناك صعوبه في الدخول
الى سوريا ومطالبه امريكيه بالابقاء على
معبر باب الهوى مفتوح حتى تتمكن من ايصال
المساعدات الى سوريا لكن هي تعترف بانه
ربما هناك صعوبه بالمقارنه مع تركيا معصول
كل هذه الفرق الى الداخل لكن على كل
الاحوال هذه الفرق فرق الانقاذ والبحث هي
مدربه
كما ذكرنا عبر ساعات طويله من التغطيه
بالامس بانه بالفعل كان هناك خبره طويله
لبعض هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين عملوا في
الكوارث الطبيعيه في محاوله انقاذ الناجين
والعالقين هناك كلاب مدربه هناك الات
حديثه يمكن ان تكشف عن اولئك الذين
موجودين تحت الانقاذ حتى الان اسمحي لنا
انتقل الى موسكو عبد الجواد رشد عبد
الجواد مع الدعوات الدوليه للضغط من قبل
موسكو على نظام الاسد للسماح او لتوزيع
المساعدات على كل الشعب السوري ما هي رده
الفعل الروسيه على هذه الدعوه وماذا عن
الروسيه التي بدات تصل الى دمشق
مساء الخير ليان لك والي الزملاء طبعا
موسكو ترى في هذه القضيه بان الخيار والحل
والقرار بهذا الموضوع هو مرتبط بدمشق بشكل
مباشر لكن طبعا اذا ما دار الحديث حول
الدور الروسي بما يخص عمليه الاغاثه في
الاراضي السوريه فان دور موسكو طبعا ينقسم
الى جزئين الاول بداته موسكو يوم امس عبر
مركز المصالحه الروسي بنشر العديد من
قواتها ومعداتهم في المحافظات الثلاثه
الاكثر ضررا وهي حلب واللاذقيه وحماه طبعا
اكثر من 300 عنصر تحدثت عنهم وزاره
الطوارئ الروسيه واكثر من 60 قطعه من
المعدات التقنيه تقوم الان بعمليات البحث
وازاله اثار يعني الدمار الذي خلفه هذا
الزلزال طبعا هذه الفرق قامت بانشاء مشفى
ميداني وانشاء العديد من النقاط
تسهيل عمل الراغبين بالتبرع بالدم بحيث ان
التقارير الوارده من هناك تتحدث عن ان
الوضع الانساني كارثي الان بشكل كبير طبعا
الدور الثاني هو وصول طائرات تابعه لوزاره
الطوارئ الروسيه صباح اليوم الى الاراضي
السوريه هذه الطائرات اقلت اكثر من خمسين
مختصا بما يعني يخص عمليه الانقاذ والبحث
عن ناجين من تحت الدمار هذا الكبير
والعديد من الاليات وفرق من الكلاب
المدربه للبحث عن هؤلاء الاشخاص شكرا لك
عبد الجواد سانتقل الى الزميل حسين نادر
من باريس حسين يعني كيف ستتعاطى الحكومه
الفرنسيه اليوم مع ايصال المساعدات الى
سوريا خصوصا وانها لا تعترف بشرعيه النظام
هناك ماذا عن المناطق المعارضه وعن مناطق
الخاضعه لسيطره النظام وطبعا ماذا عن
المساعدات الى تركيا
نعمه في الواقع العيال المساعدات الى كل
من تركيا وسوريا تمر عبر اربعه مسارات
وزاره الخارجيه وزاره الداخليه بلديه
باريس
وتحالف من ست منظمات انسانيه طبعا
المساعدات الى سوريا تمر حصرا عبر
المنظمات الانسانيه وهذه المنظمات
الفرنسيه عددها كبير اذكر منها على سبيل
المثال منظمه اطباء العالم منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود
كارفرانس بالاضافه الى منظمات الدوليه
تنشط من ضمنها فرنسا مثل اليونيسف والصليب
الاحمر الدولي على سبيل المثال منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود قدمت مساعدات الى 23 مؤسسه
صحيه في كل من حلب وادلب وجوارهما امدتهما
ام ادت هذه المؤسسات الثلاث والعشرين بين
مستشفيات وعيادات طبيه امدتها منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود بفرق طبيه وبمعدات طبيه
وقبل ساعات من الان بل
ظهر اليوم وصلت الى تركيا فرق انقاذ
الفرنسيه بالاضافه الى المئه وتسعه
وثلاثين عنصر من عناصر فرق الانقاذ
والاطفاء التي اعلن عنها امس ايضا غادرت
مطار في شمال فرنسا فرقه من عشره متخصصين
ينتمون الى المجموعه الفرنسيه للنجده من
الكوارث هؤلاء توجهوا الى غازي عنتاب
ووصلوا بعيده ظهر اليوم سيستمر تحركهم على
الارض لمده ثمانيه ايام هؤلاء متطوعون
ومتخصصون في النجده من الكوارث منذ 20
عاما هؤلاء قدموا من شمال فرنسا ومن منطقه
البروتاني في الغرب الفرنسي وايضا من
منطقه النورماندي وقد وصلوا الى غازي
عنتاب بعض
ظهر اليوم اذا نعم اعود الى سؤالك
المنظمات الانسانيه الفرنسيه هي التي تهتم
تحديدا بالوضع على الارض في سوريا شكرا
لكم مراسلي العربيه حسين قنيبر من باريس
ناديه البلبيسي من واشنطن وعبد جواد الرشد
من موسكو
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا يعد احد
اكثر الزلازل تسببا في وقوع ضحايا خلال
السنوات العشر الاخيره عوامل كثيره وقفت
خلف هذا الزلزال وجعلته مميتا بينها طبعا
قربه من سطح الارض لا يمكن مشاهدينا
التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل حدوثه لاجل ذلك يصعب
تفادي تداعياته الخطيره والتي تكون احيانا
مدمره حسب قوه الزلزال بمقياس رختر لنلقي
معا نظره عامه حول كيفيه حصول الزلزال
يعرف الزلزال بانه اهتزاز ارضي مفاجئ ينتج
عن الحركه المستمره للصفائح التكتونيه
والتي تسبب تراكم الضغط على طبقات الصخور
على جانبي الصعود صدوع الواقعه بين
الصفائح مما يؤدي طبعا الى تكسر الكتل
الصخريه وانزلاقها وبالتالي اطلاق الطاقه
المخزنه في القشره الارضيه في حركه مفاجئه
ينتج عنها موجات تحمل طاقه زلزاليه تنتشر
عبر صخور الارض لتصل الى السطح كما نشاهد
هنا مما يتسبب طبعا بحدوث الاهتزازات
تتعدد الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصول الزلازل
لتشمل الزلزال التكتوني التي تعد الاكثر
شيوعا وهنا يحدث انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع
المحيط لينقسم الى عدد من الاجزاء او
الصفائح الصلبه التي تتراوح سمكتها بين
مئه ومئه وخمسين كيلومتر لتتحرك بعدها فوق
طبقه الغلاف المري التي تقع تحت قشره
الارض مباشره هناك ايضا الزلزال الزلازل
البركانيه التي تحدث بسبب البراكين
الناشطه ولكنها ليست بقوه الزلازل
التكتونيه وغير غالبا ما تحدث بالقرب من
سطح الارض ولذلك يتم الشعور بها فقط
بالقرب من نقطه منشا الزلزال يعقب حدوث
الزلازل العديد من الاحداث والاثار التي
قد تكون مدمره ويمكن ان تتخذ اشكالا
متعدده منها الانهيارات والفيضانات
والحرائق
والسيول والتربه والسوناميو
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سنكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه
للكارثه التي حلت بسوريا وتركيا كارثه لا
تتوقف فيها جهود انتشار من هم تحت الالقاب
وبالتالي لا تتوقف فيها ارقام الضحايا عن
الارتفاع والرقم الذي يتغير كل ساعه تخطى
الان
7500 قتيل في البلدين اتحدث هنا عن تركيا
وشمال سوريا طبعا ابقوا معنا في هذه
التغطيه المباشره لهذه الكارثه الانسانيه
التي حلت بالبلدين انتقل الان الى الزملاء
راويه وطاهر تفضلوا